- [Voiceover] Hello grammarians.
Now, previously we had spoken about
just the basic idea of verb aspect,
which is kind of like tenses for tenses,
and I know that's a little blah,
wheels-within-wheels ridiculous,
but we'll make sense of it.
What aspect allows you to
do is situate, more exactly,
your verbs in time, so
if you're telling a story
and you wanna indicate
when something happened
in that story, then you
would use verb tense
to indicate when it
happened, and the next layer
of complexity after that
in terms of being specific
about when stuff happens
in time is aspect,
but I'm gonna teach you today
about the simple aspect,
which I don't really need to
teach you about to be frank
because you already know what it is.
It's been staring at us this entire time.
The simple aspect is
really just the bare tense
of whatever conjugation you choose to do,
so if you're talking at the
present tense, right here,
so you say, I walk,
that's it, that simple.
It doesn't indicate anything else
about whether or not the walking
is completed or the walking is ongoing.
It's just, I walk, same
thing with the future,
I will walk, same thing
with the past, I walked.
If it doesn't have any helper verbs
for the past or the present
and the only helper verb
it has for the future is
will, then it's simple.
That's it, that's the
bare minimum required
to express the idea using that tense.
That's the simple aspect.
You can learn anything.
David out.